so this is a spoiler free review of
Avengers infinity all da there's
definitely going to be a spoiler section
because this is kind of one of the
movies it was made for and before we
start I again make a very clear where
how much we know about the infinity war
in the Infinity Gauntlet
I don't know jack-shit I read x-men and
Batman's and other Marvel Comics but I
didn't read key on the other hand I'm
gonna show you this because this has
actually been in here the whole time he
and his friends when they were kids they
actually made this picture of the
Infinity Ward each of them took apart so
that that left part somebody took that
the center you know that somebody took
that and the right part one of them took
dad that was three men that drew it and
it was actually frame there the whole
time and I bet you never even knew that
was there so Rob knows about this just
at least back when he let's let's put me
on the spot okay bye know about let's
just say yes I read it in 1993 I have
not looked at honestly I just like write
at the same time I drew their picture
like that feds and I I want to show that
off because I always think that's a cool
thing that you have framed and up there
and stuff like that like I see it all
the time nobody my friend my friend
Dan's the one who framed it but but gave
it and then gave it to me yeah gave it
to me he's got this plan to basically
pass it around he's like everybody gets
it for 10 years apparently in a few you
like I don't know I think three or four
years whenever my time's up I have to
give it to my other friend Steve so it's
the three of us who do it pass on it but
you don't care about that you are yeah
so I'm just gonna say if I get something
wrong about don't let the infinity war
infinity crusade or something I have
read the damn thing since the early 90s
so just just know that going in like but
you have more of a frame of reference
I have only Nomura but I have more of a
frame of reference I am only going off
of the move you are going in blind he at
least read it a long long time ago he
has some frame of reference uh with that
said I can walk this movie I did you I
this is my top I live maybe top three
made Dharma movie ok I really like civil
war yeah I don't know if it's top 5 but
I will say this I liked it better than
Avengers and Avengers age of Ultron
which never that never crack the top 5
for me never did no it's a fun movie
yeah it's a very impressive movie uh
this feels like and I get most people
probably know that this is part one of
them II all these movies are continuing
this very clearly is a part one there's
gonna be another one yeah I felt like
this is just a straight-up comic-book
movie all these characters are
established every time it cuts to
somebody else it's a person I like I was
saying I can't think of one character in
this movie I like my except hipper pots
and she said it for a minute there's
nobody I dislike there are as I was
telling you at the end we were talking
during credits there are some characters
where it's just like oh yeah they exist
not because I hate their characters but
because this movies there's a lot of
example of characters that's like Black
Widow shows up and it's literally just
like I'm here I'm gonna fight some
people there you go I think she had like
four lines I mean even white one after
it has like five lines and he's like can
we offer my cute I think that's still
showing actually as we're doing this
review that there's two Marvel movies
out like I would say like there's
there's been like some discussion did
Disney not realize that black panther
was gonna be this huge and should there
have been more kind of in this movie
considering what I hit it and I the
whole like last chunk of this is in
Wakanda did like I mean you you could
have been like okay we could have got a
little more black panther or some of the
characters but there's about as much
black panther in this movie as in white
my emails 100 but yeah no I there's a
lot of what kinda in this yeah honestly
I kind of was like the second they went
to Wakanda I was like yes I'll say that
I mean like how do I put I feel like
people that would dislike this movie
would proudly say it jumps around a lot
which it does and there's not it's
mostly like well now we gotta do this
because this thing is happening this
thing is happening ok and then a little
character in it now we gotta do this is
good this thing is that this thing is
happening but again I feel like people
know that going in it's still these
characters you like they're still
explaining it in their unique way we're
seeing how they interact off each other
and nothing I I kind of want a movie
where it feels like that's happening
with this because in something like the
first Avengers I can't remember it's
cool seeing them together but they're
kind of just not doing much for like the
first half of the movie and this was
just immediately it gets going and it's
throwing mmm this movie is big and
this movie is dumb and that's exactly
what it needed to be I don't like I just
think it feels epic yeah I mean but it
but it's also it's also a comic book
movie it's kind of dumb fun quality and
I'm just like and I you know these are
the same guys who did you know Winter
Soldier in Civil War and I felt like
Winter Soldier is what it needed to be
I feel like this maybe is a little
closer to something like civil war where
it's it's like we can get insanely dark
but then they look spider-man's here's
all goofy like and I don't have a
problem with that because I think what
Marvel does that I like is and
particularly they showed it with black
panther you get enough of a variety I
know some people like Omar who's always
goofy it's a second no there's there's
ups and downs and you know for every
black panther you can have a movie like
i can't man yeah or you can have a movie
like this which i think is just that
perfect like kind of mix of dark and
good but honestly I honestly think it
worked better here than it did even in
civil war because civil war with so much
of like kind of a spy thriller in amia
and then and then just like this
30-minute goofy battle at an airport
whereas this one I felt like it starts
off a little goofy but it it's segues
into some dark terror
maintains this kind of tone where it's
like you're with these characters
because they have a sense of humor they
seem like decent people but but that's
why it hurts when you see them hurt yeah
it really does I think it obviously that
I'd honestly probably enjoy be better in
this movie that I'm like Civil War I I i
compare it to like my top faves
like I love Civil War I love guardians
of the galaxy - I think this is very
close to know that it has a lot less but
it's got a lot of weight to it as well
and a lot of it is in the guardians I
mean it's all the Marvel Universe but
within that universe you got these kind
of subset universes a lot of this seems
set in the guardians universe which I
love that's my favorite yeah part of the
Marvel Universe at least in the films is
the guardians universe of the fact that
so much of it takes place kind of in
that realm like just I'm totally on
board
well I can't what you said that there's
no way they're gonna get everybody in
that screen time and not everyone is
gonna have an arc or a big story going
on stuff like that but I mean again
there is something so nice and so cool
about seeing a giant movie where all the
people all the characters you see not
only do you recognize but you like them
and you don't want to see how bad things
happen to them when something does you
feel bad and the audience feels bad only
somebody from the past shows up that
maybe of Xena Wyler didn't think would
ever show up again like it gets a big
reaction from the audience I think what
makes the movie work and this is where
DC DC WB I could we got a blame put
blame baby they keep saying DC Warner
Brothers I think this is where Warner
Brothers blew it is this as I said the
movies like big and dumb it is it
there's some cool stuff with fan o's and
there's some you know heartfelt
emotional stuff but you know we're not
talking necessarily high art it is
totally a comedy
yeah it's Depok comic book movie and it
doesn't lose track of that and the plot
you could say is just almost just kind
of razor thin of just like do this do
that just running around and doing
things is like we need to get the blobby
believe to do this it is like well we'll
stop that as by doing
ah he's got this gym that could do this
and it's all like that but what makes it
work is that Marvel spent so much time
10 years now building up right yeah all
of these characters and even if there's
characters you don't like or even some
of the film's I don't like you know like
I still can't remember Iron Man 2 what
the hell happened there's Mickey Rourke
of whips and parrots or something like
we've spent so much time building up
those characters that you can afford to
throw them in something that just is
really just like hey let's watch our
favorite characters get together fight
and save the universe and it's not
really a deep really super deep story or
complicated story but and you would
argue that's like well where's all the
character because it's just them
punching people it's like the characters
are already there you don't need to felt
like it's the blanks have all been
filled in with 10 years of films so I
can go into this and I just was totally
just like laughing and having a blast
and like getting goose bumps you know
when spider-man shows up or when you
know Ironman shows up and they're all
working together and doing these things
and the cause of this yeah well and
here's something to hide argue that
there are there is still character and
death and dramatic moments but again it
works like a comic yeah it works where
you've established these people like
okay example Avengers to the scene
everyone pretty much liked what was the
scene in the cabin now that's like a
movie it's people coming together yeah
tolik they're discussing it field stuff
like that does happen and counts but not
much not like the Marvel comics and the
superhero comics all the stuff that
happens in here I can see on a panel I
can see these coming outward bubbles
they're like that's the same emotions
you have in the comics years and years
of people yeah but it's it's not some
gritty independent film like we're
talking about their emotions for an hour
around the dinner table yeah there are a
couple scenes like that but I'm saying
like so much of it it's just people
punching each other and I'm okay like
that I'm okay with that because I know
who these characters are I don't we
don't need like if you went into this
without seeing those films I think you
would I wouldn't recommend it really
you have to know the movie you have to
know at least some of the big characters
and and that's the thing like I think if
you don't know these characters you
would watch this movie like and I think
there's a couple critics who have and we
may know them even but who are just like
I don't Kenneth but people just punch of
each other like it this plot makes no
sense and it's just like but yeah if
you've seen the previous tenant like
watching return the King without seeing
the other crew two films I like it's not
gonna have the same impact or making
money if you didn't follow it and I also
know that in a role and that's the
difference I think with the WB films is
that they didn't do that they like two
films they beta rial before they got to
there and then they got to Justice
League and it just felt rushed hastily
assembled pushed out I mean there were
other problems too obviously with the
director having to leave and then they
brought in Jess weed but it it just
never worked because you didn't have
that firmly established connection you
did maybe with Wonder Woman that's one
mm-hmm but you know flash Aquaman all
these other ones that you have in there
and it's just like that's what Marvel
did and that's what makes it so
brilliant the high I don't know really
if we're ever gonna even see that again
like because it's just such a huge
investment for ten years yeah well I
mean obviously we see other Studios
trying to do it but I mean the closest
we've done is probably DC which is not
doing it that well and yeah you're right
this is probably the only one to pull it
off and it is still mind-blowing how
well they're pulling this off even
though not every movie is great or
phenomenal everything it's still that
their checklist is just incredible like
unprecedent you've never seen a
checklist of so many good movies they
have been connected and all add up to
something and it kind of gets bigger and
bigger and it's just it's amazing how
they're doing this and I feel like it
builds up to something really good you
know again this is only a part one so
we'll see how part two does as well but
for a part one I really enjoyed it
um but I think I think that's an
important point because I know that some
people we've talked to or where we just
look at just combined me of Justice
League bunch of people punching each
other I didn't follow the plot and then
but I'm like no that was heavier look
that's the thing that that is the
difference you know that marble
basically spent their time building up
these characters my dad I don't know
Aquaman I don't know flash I don't know
cyborg no I mean and I'm just saying
once again it's just a shame because I
think a lot of DC characters are grave
and I think basically the studio over
there gave them the shaft and I
I don't know maybe they shouldn't even
try maybe they should just focus on
doing individual honestly they should
just focus on doing the individual films
and then at some point if they're just
like alright we know these characters
enough now let's try it but instead they
went backwards they're like we've got to
have the T movie when yesterday I think
they think this is a long lasting fad
and in some respects it is but I don't
think even they predicted how long it
was gonna go I think they thought maybe
five six years we're on year 10 and it
is still going ridiculously strong so I
think they felt they had to rush it out
you know really get them out there
before this bad dice down but it's only
getting bigger and bigger because the
movies are getting bigger and bigger and
they're adding more and more different
steps to it whatever the reason it just
bothers me because I see this and I'm
just like well there you go
and yet it's still like you would look
at it almost be like well it's kind of
half the same stuff they doing something
like Justice League but it's like all
that build-up well I know these people
yeah movies and they've all had did it
and then meanwhile over here cuz I like
Wonder Woman and Batman and Superman as
characters I'm just like like I
want them to push even even some
characters
I think cared that much about I found my
soul I kin the other films I find myself
caring much more for them and this one I
cared a lot more for Gamora I cared
Pharaoh's good Christ that was the
biggest surprise
Bannos based on the trailers I saw was
gonna so as soon as I it's as I saw with
Josh Brolin even under the CG which is
very good by the way
I was like no I have not seen the
battery sir I have not seen a bad
performance from it and I'm not saying
that it was gonna be a bad performance
but I was what he brings so much to
everybody know this guy watching the
trailer there is something about the
trail and I don't know if they improve
the effects are just played better on
the big screen but there's something
about the trailer where Dana so it's
really fake he didn't look been
intimidating me all the shots they
picked in the trailer for some reason
rubbed me the wrong way see that like
none of the other movies yeah literally
like a like two minutes into this when
he shows up I was like oh crap maybe I
was wrong in almost every scene he is in
he freakin owns it Owens every scene
your eyes are on him the whole time yeah
and uh yeah you know what we complain
about CG a well for example I could
Justice League that CG monstrosity
villain that was you know that was
Thanos Duncan free mr. Potato Head
Superman is amazing upper lip it's
appalling but the CG they do on a mirror
you know it doesn't always look
convincing but the performance comes
through and a lot of time it does look
very good for a purple dude walking
around you know supposed to be double
the size of everybody and they bring
through the performance I think that's
the biggest thing in Josh Brolin it is
such a presence and I think he's he sold
it like in a way that I thought because
in the comics I just took it for granted
like a giant purple guy with a prune
face like you know it and like he was
intimidating in the comics I thought he
was super cool but yeah is when I
started to see him popping up in the
films and then the trailer I'm just like
I know if I'm able to take this
seriously maybe this only works on the
comic book panel they did so I think by
the way they they sold it they did
something that was so clever that first
I thought was you know for a couple
seconds I thought oh this isn't gonna
work
and then it won me over so quickly in
all the other movies even though I know
we're only didn't didn't play him wet
when he's there it was he's over he was
on pure armor he sounds exactly like you
would think a character like that would
sound and when they do it it's only his
voice I don't think
add a bass or treble or an echo or
anything and it just instantly gives
humanity to this character to a
character that honestly I'm still not a
hundred percent what his motivation is
but but I can tell you it's even more
it's it's weirder even in the comic I
can tell you cuz they eliminated they
took out a ton of stuff but but you know
what he reminds me of uh he reminds me
of Maleficent from Sleeping Beauty the
dumbest motivation for a villain but by
guys she is so charming and so elegant
and just so interesting that and the
performance is so great that you buy it
and you go along with it it's the same
thing here it's like okay something
about you have to wipe out half of
humanity in order to gain control and
keep it going as that something really
no idea like his whole arc is because
there's like the infinity is so
basically they call this one the
infinity war but it's really more like
the Infinity Gauntlet and he's putting
them gauntlet together still
and then the Infinity Ward was sequel I
think there was like it was infinity
crusade maybe but he's arc through that
like I'll tell you sometime like it's
just like a traditional comic well yeah
it's you'd be watching it based on where
you started thinking of this guy
basically as a super villain or whatever
by the end of it you're like what like
it's so I'm very curious where they're
going with all of this in this series
because it's it's way way different from
what I remember we're missing like what
we're missing the main character warlock
isn't here and then there is a character
that basically Thanos was trying to how
would you put it impress court I don't
know but there's like the the mistress
of death or something so there's that
care and that character is missing and
there's also this is definitely like
it's more like loosely based on the
Infinity Gauntlet like this we know they
can't do they can't do the Fantastic
Four they can't bring silver yea and
Silver Surfer had a huge role
um so but I'm very interested
particularly with the way this movie
ends and where they're going with it
what they're gonna do cuz I'm like some
of this just seems like uncharted
territory for me I'm just like I don't
remember any of this in the Infinity
Gauntlet saga or whatever so and is the
next one then like is this all just
gonna be Infinity Gauntlet based are we
going to somehow get around to the
infinity war or infinity crusade are we
gonna ever have warlock or there may
just manages whatever his name is or
like bringing vittatus and I don't know
it's like can this thing just go on
forever they're gonna do even our weave
is that what we're gonna do have the
infinity war infinity Crusade another
ten years from now or like so I don't
know it's it's kind of just fascinating
because I'm just like having read the
comics I'm just like wow that this is
all way different like I recognize it as
like based on a story from Infinity
Gauntlet but I'm I'm very curious where
the hell they're going because I don't
know you know I love all the Marvel
villains again I could break down on one
hand how many I like legitimately really
found interesting and intriguing and if
Thanos again kind of has vanos no no I
was like family gave you honey I always
like to oh no no no I'm talking about
just in the movies Oh in the movies
comics are great cause I've already
announced a movie something in like the
Bulger yeah Walter and Dan Hawks yeah
and Loki Loki on and off again a little
bit of Kurt Russell from guardians to
but they give me even Kurt Russell again
they have the same thing where it's like
well obvious this has to be dying in
order to achieve peace I did love the
main villain from guardians that the
Kree warrior that's doing the dance of
what are you doing well that but but
that's awesome but but no but you know
what any we're still that same thing
where well I have to obviously do this
thing which is obviously bad but we'll
we to world peace somehow and it you
know it's still kind of that thing but I
don't he's the only one I watch and I'm
just like I I play I believe you've been
around for years and years and years and
you're like
no this is what you really feel you have
to do and every reaction has face just
projects that just know if there's
there's really no other alternative and
he's nice he's not gonna try to convince
anybody that's the thing without he's
bad why can't you see why Kay he's just
well I don't concur more I think more i
he's trying to convince a little but
everybody else is like no I'm just I'm
doing this cuz it's right the end I
don't even know if he is for good Maura
come on he's just like none you know
like he's the fact he's talking to her
at all I think again he sees his like
mercy you know because it will all
they've been through together and stuff
like that but he's I don't know a
relationship that was that maybe the
strongest thing in this movie is is her
in fan o's yeah cuz i'm like that was a
weird twisted like relationship that
then i'm like that would i thought for
me personally like on a character level
was the most interesting thing in it
because everything else was mostly just
plot point base hey yeah this do that
punch this guy punch that guy yeah come
up with a plan but that was the only
thing that is the core the film it's
it's star-lord and his father basically
from guardians to like it's like that is
the center of the film somehow is
Stannis and Gomorrah and I thought that
really really work and I like that every
single time he gets one of these
Infinity stones I like any movie that
gets me to say oh no I love it here
because there's not many movies that get
me to do that anymore
this was a movie where it's like kind of
we can't predict what's gonna happen I
mean honestly like you know I read the
comic there are some things they did to
them like I think I could have predicted
down no no no but I mean like okay like
they're building up will this and like
will hit stones like from a marketing
standpoint you know what has to happen
but it's one of those things where it's
like still when it happens I like that
movie kind of sucks me in so much I kind
of forget I also like that there again
your time of the last third takes place
and what kinda I it to me like this this
is the climax I wanted like Panther this
is the be a great one that's the weird
thing I say the last third takes poison
Wakanda but it's chunks of last there
because then you're also cross-cutting
across the gallery Titan and then
I forget the name of the visit this is
bread the first adventure of the movies
where not many changes together there's
yeah where they're all together um
well and I think but I like that I think
that's a good move because I think
that's what we're gonna want to see in
the sequel yes huge huge things could be
like that picture over there yeah it's
gonna and that's another thing I liked
was like what I do remember about the
infinity Wars saga just as a whole is
battles in space hmm and I like that
part of this movie knowing like wouldn't
say like fan O's just like forgive me
brings a moon down you know I'm just
like that's what I remember from the
comics I hear have a moon like that kind
of thing
yeah I think like the only the only
nitpicky problems I have with this movie
and they really are nitpicky is that
every time I see these Marvel movies or
all these characters get together
particularly like Doctor Strange and fan
OHS and stuff like I'm always like we
aren't there like 20 different things
they can do here that they're not people
if I'm getting on a bike yeah you
definitely think one of the problems I
had was just the characters all make the
same stupid choice but there's one
there's like the matically maybe it's
like yeah like I'll be Vega but like a
well-loved really love love love and
isn't it but they all like when it's
there to being insisted upon like no
screw of we need to save the galaxy like
they all make the same dumb choice and
then I love them but I'm like I don't
think they would do that I I kind of
disagree and goes but the the one near
the end is the one now you all know
what's so funny cuz that's the one that
I'm like I'll buy that no no have not
that character no no at first I thought
the same thing but then when he says his
line and yet we got going the spoiler
corner it it won me I mean why there's
more than meets the eye
yes oh and the corner few I was actually
impressed how many characters did make
it the choice uh you know it doesn't
always work out that way but how many
you were just like look if this happens
if it happens you have to do be and I
was impressed how many characters did do
be they did but there's that one in that
will time answer that whatever um like
what yeah I I do think it is a long
movie and it is kind of delivered we
play deliberately placed deliberately
paste if parts somewhere in the middle
and sometimes in the last third I was
just kind of like yeah squirming a bit
like but it really wasn't much that I
was just like oh my god I'm so bored
like get me out of this theater like and
there are us there are a lot of applause
points
yeah the only like four or five I think
a lot of gasps - oh yeah which again I
love when that happens in a movie which
I think cuz we had somebody else who
went I think to a critic screening it
was like oh they were all just so bored
and just and I'm just like I'll tell you
I think there's a difference sometimes
between like an audience reaction who
are fans of something and critics cuz
I'm just like man the screaming I saw
they were all really into it but the
only part I can think of where I was I
was legit like okay can we just wrap
this part up is there's a scene where
Thor's making a new hammer and I felt
like okay that could have been cotton
that X it was an you know I wanted to
save that you know first one other
Carnaby you know there's some of the
other spoilers anyway so yeah that's the
only scene where I found kiss it's like
no no now you have to hold on to the
ship
no now you have to be projected into the
star no no now you and we have to get
the ax - um no now we need a handle for
the axe I'm like this really long ago be
and I don't know long but was like yeah
everything else was pretty entertained
by uh and maybe on a second viewing that
would be more bored by it but like the
first time around I was like I was
really impressed how much I was like no
I'm concerned about that character no I
want the relationship to work you know I
told my mind
character of guardians and I think
that's why I like and I think that's why
I would go back and and own it on
blu-ray and watch it again they remind
me of guardians to there's Avengers like
an age of Ultron I'm just like yeah I
really don't watch it hardly ever like
and I'm not saying they're bad movies
I'm like that's perfectly fine but it's
I don't go back to it but guardians 1 &
2 I go back to all the time and this is
one that I might go back to cuz I'm just
like I like this universe and the fact
that it has the guardians in it I think
helps play a big part I like that they
split them up to the guardians in half I
thought that was very smart and to have
them interact with different characters
and stuff there's a it might be very
clever usage of Peter Dinklage in this
movie oh and the minute I saw two Peter
Dinklage
which I feel a little bad cuz I was
saying that it piercing which is an
amazing actor like he's one of my top
faves I do feel bad doing away my no
thing I do feel a little bad that
whenever there's a par for a dwarf it's
like it always goes there's that out but
here it's totally amazing though because
amazed and never seen a bad performance
from that day a lot of pixels was kind
of bad it's really really amazing and I
just kind it's both goes for it against
type when you think about it yeah no I
that's what I thought about it well even
even if you took someone that was not
Peter Dinklage just this idea I think is
clever because it's like again without
giving away too much you know they say
we have to go visit the dwarves and
there's like only one door flap and when
you see them unthinking cuz you know we
think that one or two things when you
hear door if you hear one of the rings
you know trying but little people and
then you think of you know someone like
Peter Dinklage you know a smaller person
but with this one when you see him it's
like oh I've seen that done before that
100% makes sense I love that I think
that's something else I want to comment
on as somebody who's had a hit in this
relationship with the Thor films it I'm
really like completely unboard with Thor
like I'm just right away for my Thor
he fried my favorite.i in the firt like
and is a mess but I think my wife put it
best so what she just dropped natalie
portman from the mailman ahead and i'm
like yeah like maybe that was the
problem I don't know but it's she he has
been good from the first one to now he I
don't think he's been bad I just there's
something about that came off as bland
and I feel like between Thor 3 and now
this I'm just like man I just I want
more Thor just give me as much to give
me so much doors that can handle that's
because he just like and I think part of
it maybe because like his character has
gone through so much it's another thing
like that conversation they're having
he's having with rabbit rabbit though
with raggedy this is like about how much
he's lost and stuff and I'm just like
yeah like just really a boy this game
and what seemed like kick some ass
it's the first time we see him like like
he's always I mean he's that dignified
place very goofy he's first thing you
know one of these he's very civilized
but he's a very silly character still
it's the first time I've seen him or
I've taken him seriously
yeah nice legit badass pissed off like
I'm gonna make people goddamn pay and
and you buy it you totally buy it you
know it isn't him just swinging the
hammer around
it's like taking a character like mr.
peanut butter from Bojack horseman and
then just like killing everyone around
him and now he's out for revenge and
it's just like wow I didn't know it's
like I just that was I think the biggest
character shift
I think van and Thanos are the two
biggest character shifts where I'm just
like I'm really on board with like both
these two like in this film like I want
more of them like the one whose powers I
think got more impressive the Scarlet
Witch is there her name yeah yeah I
thought her power it's like this before
it's like okay and she's cool she's fine
move some stuff around cool whatever in
this one like the she's doing I was
just like damn I don't know she could do
that the spider-man suit also at first I
thought wasn't gonna like but it doesn't
goddamn cool things no I it was it was
fun to see Parker back well ok something
else we talked
about how we're sick of spider-boy we
were just sick to death of it but I
realize no here it is needed when you
see them with everybody I'm like damn he
does have a very unique identity because
everyone else has grown up and he's like
the only kid you know he's like the
Robin to the group and so it's like that
doesn't yeah a different point well a
different dynamic and that is the
problem is that wasn't the case in the
comics cuz I mean in the comics we're
talking about that was like early 90s
were we're grown-up Peter Parker
post-college
yeah which is spider-man I remember in
the spider-man I really like and yeah so
a part of me at first I was just when he
showed up I'm like oh cool but a part of
me is like oh god we got spider boy now
in the infinity war like and you nailed
it like it's because unlike the comic
there's no other youthful characters so
he's like a breath of fresh air and I'm
like damn it yeah he works he has with
Stark I mean yeah wonderful I'm really
well done I said this is great I was
like what is he like your Wars I'm like
yeah it's getting that creepy kind of
Batman Robin level like old-school like
but when you see how it just keeps
building and building on high you could
argue what it builds up to uh it it's
really believable and it's really solid
a mecha that the scene at the end that
could have been so awkward and gimmicky
and I just felt a 100% worked no it it
did a man that could have completely
just yeah I feel like there's a lot of
scenes in this movie the web to talk
about spoiler : yeah that could have
just totally fell apart and surprisingly
were cuz I think you nailed it there's
just all the movies they've established
that they've given there was no scenes
for me that just fell apart or felt
completely flat because your mind fills
in the blanks with everything you've
seen before for the past ten years yes
they're so well established and that's
what I want from other franchises and
that always seems to be a problem maybe
maybe the other ones just should even
bother trying like maybe this is like
you know what this is lightning struck
once it's not gonna repeat itself just
let them do it with this thing but it's
I look
back and I'm like 10 years of this I'm
just like what do you love them or hate
them
I know there are some critics out there
is like everything's comic book movies
and there's the bling and I it's like
what they freaking accomplish though
like it's kind of changed the face of
film in some ways at least to the impact
it's had in a genre of movie making
that's something like Star Wars did
comic book movies to this degree like
yeah we had Tim Burton's Batman yeah we
have Richard Donner's who read they were
like big hits and then they always
fizzled out and this is just still just
getting bigger a new money-making
juggernaut
well that's affected the whole industry
now like it's all this what love it or
hate it like and even if you hate it you
got to respect them like well they
changed the freaking landscape yeah the
franchises I can think of that a rip
they've really kind of changed to film
like in the past I now know 30 40 years
the end of the Star Wars Lord of the
Rings yeah um sci-fi fantasy and the
nice comic book movies well I was gonna
say I mean like even though I'm not I
don't get into them but Harry Potter has
to I mean that is worth noting and and
these Marvel films I mean I think these
are films that just these have not yeah
really been done Lord of the Rings I
feel they were released pretty much
simultaneously so you could count either
one yeah I mean they're hotter when I
say Lord the rims I'm literally implying
Potter with it like they were both out
there at the same yeah by me the idea
how many movies was like in like eight
movies and they about every year and
given that I mean that's that's a feat
that's an impressive fee and everyone
you know was a big hit so yeah I think
those films are kind of all together you
have really changed sort of like in
terms of like really big blockbuster
filming and entertainment and yeah as
much as I get it I get out people are
like I'm sick of comic book movies I'm
sick of a you're still gonna go see you
okay yeah I keep saying it that I'm like
yeah I'm getting kind of sick of that
but then I go see
yeah and I'm just like yeah there's a
fun waste of time I I think this was
better than just a fun waste of time
yeah and I agree this was one of the
better ones I don't know if it's in my
top 5 but considering how many Marvel
films there are it doesn't need to be
his sister yeah it's just like you could
be in the top 10 in stuff this is would
be made my top 10 like easily like I'll
say this if Thanos was not done well I
don't know if it'd be in my top 5 I he
really again the Joe Nolan the
technology I want elite in my head to
the male get I think he and Gamora kind
of save the movie from just being an
action another yeah and then there are
heavy scenes don't get me wrong you know
it's still wet but there's where like
the weird before of the film or obvious
like that's what I'm good cuz when all
the the punching and stuff is done and
even some of the other heavy scenes up
when I think about this movie I'm gonna
be thinking of those two that's what I'm
gonna remember as the images in my head
is gonna be mostly around those two I'm
gonna remember wait to this movie and it
does come from I didn't yeah really is
both of them to mean a little bit more
Thanos but but yeah I mean she because
again with Gamora I mean like the other
like the first movie I saw her I'm like
okay she's kind of just straight no fun
whatever then the second once you got a
little bit more interesting and I okay
good thing with the sister and then this
one I'm just like I I'm suddenly really
interested in you like you yeah and it
is because unlike other franchises you
know it's like oh whoa she's the no fun
one in guardians but what did we learn
that she was working for Thanos that she
betrays Thanos see her to build up
things you know and even if her part
wasn't this huge in the second one you
know it still was bringing out a little
more character but because we saw her do
all those things when you get to this
point here you don't need mountains of
exposition know with gamora's character
it's like and that is the trouble it's
just like if you haven't been following
these movies you'd be totally lost like
but um yeah and I figure if you if you
haven't why are you here why I want to
check out this thing called movies
I think I will start with infinity to
war well I didn't understand that at all
movies suck I think that's why and I
think that's why Gomorrah really works
in this movie I could get it's the two
feet you can't have a nose without
Gomorrah and vice versa in this film and
I think I like that about this movie a
lot yeah so Paradis that will explain
more in a spoiler corner but we really
liked it man and I think that I mean
everyone knows it's gonna be a hit but
it was fun I what do you think you think
I'm allowed to play you think I'll be
bigger than Black Panther you think I'll
go longer black panther was pretty damn
impressive I don't know yeah I say cuz
that was like a monster movie that that
went for like months that Panther is a
few more things going for it including
just some things like I think it was
shorter and compared to this you're
probably right but it also weren't as
mixed it's more of like the I don't feel
like The Lion King narrative of like
it's it's more of a self-contained
self-contained narrative like this one
it's like you really kinda have to be a
devoted fan like I feel like Black
Panther drew more people in because they
were seeing a self-contained movie
whereas this one it's just like you
better have seen all these damn Marvel
movies like and I think that'll keep
some people away and I think the length
I think it'll do well though oh yeah I
can't see that's not doing well I I
think this will do I haven't checked the
Rotten Tomatoes score but I feel like I
think it was like you need a upper I was
gonna say that sounds about right to me
I was like I feel like there's a few
that are not gonna like it but I was
like I feel like this would be an
overall well received films yeah
so yeah I been watching the Marvel
movies if you check it out and I things
free being pretty epic and it's like I
said I mean surprisingly it was really
cool and my face it's another one that
seems like when they were all like it's
like spider-man and Iron Man and Doctor
Strange finding aliens and it's like
your favorite character is like working
together it's like I got that stupid
little giddy smile on my face again it's
something I know growing up like I
really wasn't doing it like I mean and
you
more of these than me by me growing up
like reading these comics you always
kind of imagined this stuff on the big
screen but you didn't think you're gonna
see it and yeah it's different and it's
but it's like yeah the fact that we're
even it's close I know in the comments
just when they do the crossover is you
get that sort of like wow that's awesome
it would be cool to see like the x-men
and The Avengers fighting together to
save the gowns and like all these sort
of things and then that's like now when
you're 38 and you finally see it on the
big screen there is just something weird
just like wow I I didn't really ever
think in 1993 that like this was gonna
happen
yeah and it says you know as much money
is being put into its ass big ahead and
they're still going and I don't know you
might have hit something there like this
might be like just the one long long
stretch of time where this happens and
Marvel might be the only one you know
that actually achieves that I mean maybe
in the future something else will come
and sort of keep going and get bigger
and bigger but yeah I feel like this
might be kind of like that on lightning
and I like movies they give me that
nostalgic feeling of being like a kid
again and you know it did that and
that's impressive not a lot of films
really do that I also like films that
kids can see but and be traumatized
if you bring a little kids they gonna
cry there's a there's some real Empire
Strikes Back go and I asked Murphy
yeah so it's ya know I was I was
definitely thinking there weren't a ton
of kids in our because it's not a night
but I'd be be hilarious see like the
weekend showings and just like even when
the movie was done like the audience was
like there are a couple moments were
likely rages Irwin loved it one movie
came out of it so yeah that's our
thoughts man go check it out
you